i am deeply sorry this is an apology
decades in the making from pope francis
in front of thousands in muskrats
alberta through an interpreter it's his
first attempt at atonement for
atrocities at canada's institutions of
assimilation known as residential
schools
i am sorry
i ask forgiveness
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i ask forgiveness in particular for the
ways in which many members of the church
and of religious communities cooperated
not least through their indifference
in projects of cultural destruction
and forced assimilation
promoted by the governments of that time
which culminated in the system of
residential schools
good evening global national is in
edmonton tonight for the pope's visit to
canada he delivered his historic apology
about an hour south of here in
musquitches it was home to one of
canada's largest residential schools the
pope says he feels shame for what
indigenous people suffered and calls the
abuse a deplorable evil committed by so
many christians
what our christian faith tells us
is that this was a disastrous error
incompatible with the gospel of jesus
christ
it is painful
to think of how the firm's soil of
values
language and culture that made up the
authentic identity of your peoples was
eroded
in that you have continued to pay the
price for this
while some people feel his apology is
meaningless the crowd and muskwitries
responded with cheers heather urex west
was there where the pope visited the
sacred heart church and spoke to
parishioners
as a day school survivor and the
daughter granddaughter and sister to
many family members who attended
residential school gilda sousay spent
most of her life outside the catholic
faith growing up i was i was
taught that the church was a bad place
because of the residential school but
after the death of her son sousse found
solace in this church our lady of seven
sorrows is a place of both catholic and
indigenous spirituality prayers are
spoken in cree in the stained glass
jesus is pictured as an indigenous man
and it was here in the first stop of his
penitential pilgrimage that pope francis
met privately with suse and other elders
from maskuchi i really truly believe in
my heart you know that healing will
happen near the site of the irmanskin
residential school an institution that
indigenous children were forced to
attend for more than 80 years the pope
prayed for those children who never made
it home children who have become
represented on this journey by a pair of
moccasins first delivered to the pope in
rome by marianne daywalker peltier in
moscow she the holy father gave those
moccasins back it was not a gift to him
it was a symbolic presentation to
represent the children that were taken
to me like i felt that
he did hear me
he did
listen to my presentation
and
it made me feel that he's a very
humble person and very kind
[Applause]
but it was these words of sorrow and
apology that so many elders residential
school survivors and their family
members had come to hear
mary spence and her family traveled 18
hours from northern manitoba it meant a
lot to me we need weekend chelation
forgiveness to be as one family in god
as how we were created sisters star
small boy and andrea rayne came on
behalf of their dad this has been a long
time
coming and so for us to be here on on
his behalf and we're just hoping that
healing would come and he would have
that
forgiveness
for him to move on and for our family to
move on of course the pope's apology was
for those watching from across canada as
well for those children whose names
appear on this long list that was walked
through the venue all of them children
who never returned home
and
for this child too
too young to fully understand the
painful past today but who in healing
might grow up in a world where
reconciliation becomes reality
[Applause]
heather the pope addressed the parish at
sacred heart a short time ago and
delivered another apology what's the
mood like there
oh me too this has been a day of very
high highs of joy and also very low lows
it's been a very painful day for for
some as well
after the pope left the parish he took
some an impromptu little walkabout and
he went to the fence and actually took
some time to greet some of the people
that had gathered there to see him
a man came out of the service and spoke
to me he was beaming he was a
residential school survivor from
northwest territories he said that he
had a chance to drum for the pope and he
had received a blessing and received a a
rosary so you know he he just felt that
the day was was very joyful and he was
very happy to hear the apology meanwhile
though while he was inside uh inside the
church there was another woman outside
beyond the fence that i spoke with and
she was also from muskochie and she was
weeping she was she told me that she was
in a lot of pain she was experiencing
trauma and throughout the day we've seen
people in
wearing blue that they've been at all
the events they've been trained to offer
mental health supports to
the people that are experiencing trauma
this is very triggering this is very
difficult for someone so you know
talking to her and seeing her receive
support was was a really stark reminder
that this is a very emotional time and
and there are so many reactions
happening it's something that the pope
spoke about inside the sacred heart
church as well he reminded the church
here and the church really across the
country that
they have to continue to do work to
support uh indigenous people as they
continue to work through
so much of their pain
in roma
in rome
after i listened to your stories
i stated that any truly effective
process of healing requires concrete
actions
so i am pleased to see that in this
parish where people of different
communities of the first nations
the metis and the inuit come together
with non-indigenous people from the
local area
and many of our immigrant brothers and
sisters
this effort has already begun
so the pope has completed his first day
of his tour and he will continue this
tour here at edmonton tomorrow nithu
thanks heather
the pope says an apology is only a first
step and an important process will be to
conduct a serious investigation into the
facts to help survivors heal
[Applause]
following the apology wilton little
child honorary chief of the earman skin
cree nation welcomed the head of the
catholic church by placing a war bonnet
on the pope
the gift was among several given to the
pope during today's historic apology but
many say it wouldn't have happened
without the revealing of at least 200
unmarked burials near the former
kamloops indian residential school in bc
nearly 15 months ago that site became
what is referred to as ground zero of
this international reckoning around
indigenous history tonight we hear how
some survivors of that institution feel
about today's events and a warning some
viewers may find the details of this
story distressing
this drumming
is medicine everett tom tells us
standing in front of the institution
that first and forever scarred him with
relentless trauma while he was only a
boy so much abuse has happened in here
the pain and the hurt you know as a
seven-year-old
i was on top of these stairs and
i wanted to throw myself off and uh
what pulled me back i don't know
you know
just
choosing to live
and to thrive after addiction controlled
his life for years into adulthood he
became a father and community pillar now
eight and a half years sober and healing
he chooses to dress himself in hope i
tossed all my other t-shirts away and i
just wear orange while holding on to
symbols of the horrors he experienced
here's the
shirt i wore home
from the residential school and
i was about seven years old by then his
mother had become an alcoholic she later
apologized to her children who were
ripped away from her i'd hold my mom's
apology
very very very high whereas i won't
accept an apology from the church
because they stole
not only my childhood but so many
childhoods each individual to be
suffering in a way
diane morgan says she spent 10 years
here we didn't have love we didn't
nobody showed you know that
they cared for us it was something that
was
distant we didn't have that so we had
each other to hang on to the whole
she's now in edmonton for the papal
visit before she left to come loops to
schwetmick she told us she wants
meaningful action and criminal
accountability for the abuses she and so
many others suffered is it just going to
be lift service for our people to hear
him being here in canada now
i'm hoping that
there is some justice done besides the
apology
my hope was for him to come here to the
countess de schwemmich knowing that this
year was ground zero the
work that i'm doing
and the messages that i'm carrying is so
important in this year time of history
everett tom has since adopted six
children from out of the indigenous
child welfare system which many now see
as a modern-day institutional extension
of the residential school framework
stopping that cycle for them and it's it
also helps heal us as well as we learn a
lot from them six is a big number you
know for us and to have
such a busy household
a lot of laughter and a lot of love the
kind he says was once stolen from him
and a reminder that if you or someone
you know who is a residential school
survivor are looking for help you can
call the residential school survivors
and family crisis line anytime the
number is 1-800-721-0066
we'll have more coverage on the pope's
historic visit later in the newscast
first there is other news to get to
tonight emergency preparedness minister
bill blair and rcmp commissioner brenda
lucky are denying interfering in the
police investigation into the nova
scotia mass shooting they were key
witnesses at a special hearing convened
by mps seeking the facts in the wake of
allegations federal officials pressured
police to push forward a new firearms
ban ross lord reports
more than two years after the living
nightmare that left 22 people murdered
the mass casualty commission's public
inquiry is hearing more admissions from
the rcmp that was communicated
a key player in the maui's response
superintendent darren campbell admits
9-1-1 information was not shared
precisely information suggesting the
gunman was driving a fully marked
replica rcmp car you can call that an
error
in
their assessment of it and why even when
it became clear the killer had escaped
their incomplete containment effort the
maudi's never initiated an emergency
alert to the public that wasn't a tool
that we were aware of that we had in our
toolbox but political admissions are
slow in coming campbell's handwritten
notes allege rcmp commissioner brenda
lucky leaned on investigators to
publicly reveal the gunman's weapons and
that lucky was pressuring to help
justify the government's upcoming gun
control legislation at a house of
commons committee in ottawa whose
hearing was timed to campbell's nova
scotia testimony commissioner lucky made
a partial admission was there pressure
for information from the federal
government about this incident
yes this wasn't surprising as we were
dealing with the biggest mass shooting
incident in our country but she insists
there was no political interference a
position shared by then public safety
minister bill blair at no point did i
direct the rcmp in any operational
matter including on public
communications other witnesses like this
former rcmp communications director
reinforce some of the allegations she
was irritated that she had briefed the
minister that we would be proactively
discussing the weapons based on my
earlier update and the organization's
former commanding officer in nova scotia
was more definitive so you heard the
commissioner say she promised the
minister and the prime minister's office
yes did the commissioner like he
directly tie that to the forthcoming
firearm policy from the liberal
government yes she did so she said the
pressure was from the minister and the
prime minister's office that she had
promised them that that information
would be released and the pressure was a
result of it being tied to the
forthcoming gun policy from the liberal
government is that correct
that's correct the nova scotia testimony
from superintendent campbell continues
tuesday in coming weeks the
parliamentary committee will also hear
from more rcmp and government witnesses
ross lord global news
a series of shootings in a vancouver
suburb have left three people dead
including the gunman it happened in
langley b.c this morning police killed
the gunman who was known to them
investigators say they're still not sure
if the victims were targeted because
they're homeless
in the hot seat over that disastrous
outage coming up the president of rogers
gets pushed for answers
we are coming to you from edmonton
tonight as pope francis's six day trip
to meet with indigenous communities in
canada has gotten underway
more on the pope in a moment but we turn
now to ottawa where rogers executives
were grilled while testifying in front
of a parliamentary committee to explain
the network outage that cut off millions
of canadians earlier this month shalema
maharaja reports on the questions raised
over the blackout that left customers
unable to communicate with their phones
use internet services or even dial 9-1-1
it's been just over two weeks since the
outage that left millions of canadians
out of touch and disconnected
appearing before the standing
parliamentary committee canada's
innovation minister isn't pulling any
punches about who's responsible it
should not be to the minister to chase
the ceo of a major taco in canada when
something like that happened it should
rather be the other way around
testifying before committee francois
philippe champagne told mps the
government is in solution mode to
prevent the next large-scale telecom
failure when i speak to them they listen
that's bottom line they don't have to
follow though well listen they do they
do trust me they do businesses across
the country were handcuffed having to
turn customers away when the interact
payment systems went down we will set a
higher standard by physically separating
our wireless and internet networks and
create an always-on network
to be frank this added layer of
protection will be expensive
we estimate it will cost at least a
quarter of a billion dollars and calls
for increased competition in the
canadian telecom space keep getting
louder in the wake of july 8th outage
isn't the concentration of customers in
one particular company a challenge to
resilience in and of itself they have
alternative and they have choice
you think canadians have alternative in
choice in this marketplace
very much so
um you're saying that with a straight
face
the minister and the government
definitely need to own a significant
component of what's happening here
because ultimately the companies will do
what the government sets in terms of
expectations according to security
expert christian loypt they haven't set
the bar high i think we need real rules
similar to what we have in the airlines
sector about what happens when there are
these kind of outages i think that we
need greater transparency and disclosure
around these issues in the meantime
rogers and its rivals have another 45
days left to meet a government deadline
to produce solutions should another
outage occur shaleema maharaj global
news ottawa
ahead ukraine's rush to reboot vital
food shipments as russia's aggression
continues
we are broadcasting from edmonton
tonight for pope francis's meetings with
indigenous communities
we'll have more on the pope's visit to
indigenous land in a moment but first
the latest out of ukraine keeves says it
hopes to once again be exporting grain
this week even after russian attacks on
the port city of odessa over the weekend
the attacks happened saturday just hours
after moscow and keeve signed agreements
with the u.n and turkey to restart grain
exports and not attack merchant ships
moving grain to market through the black
sea
russia initially denied being involved
but now says it was targeting ukrainian
military infrastructure in the area
keefe says it expects the first
shipments of grain to be exported from
its black sea ports within a few days
moscow meanwhile charged 92 captured
members of the ukrainian armed forces
today for what it calls alleged crimes
against humanity russia's investigative
committee proposed an international
tribunal backed by syria iran and
bolivia oversee their trial all
traditional allies of moscow amnesty
international has called the move a
brazen disregard for fair trial rights
and humanitarian law
the sights and sounds of healing next
another look at today's raw emotions in
muscular cheese
we're at the indigenous peoples
experience exhibit in fort edmonton park
we'll be right back
you're looking at the indigenous
people's experience in fort edmonton
park an exhibit exploring the diverse
lives cultures and histories of the
edmonton region's first nations and
metis people it was made possible thanks
to the contributions of dozens of
indigenous elders community members and
historians sharing their artifacts
memories and timeless teachings it's
where we've been reporting from tonight
on canada's latest chapter of truth and
reconciliation
today's events are just the beginning of
pope francis's week-long trip that will
see him travel to canada's north and
quebec here are some of the moments from
an emotional first day in alberta
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey
our war bonnets
are very sacred to us
war bonnets
represent leadership
of our nation
[Applause]
god
right
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
that is one of so many powerful raw
moments today as an indigenous woman
went up to the microphone to sing what
started as a rendition of o canada in
cree and evolved into calls for action
to the pope including revoking the
doctrine of discovery
that is global national for this monday
night i'm nitu garcia we'll leave you
tonight with more from muskwiches our
coverage of pope francis's journey of
truth and reconciliation with indigenous
communities will continue throughout the
week good night
hey